مشاهدينا بالعوده للقصف الامريكيه
البريطانيه الذي استهدف مواقع عده
للحوثيين في صنعاء في اليمن ينضم الينا
محمد عبد السلام الناطق الرسمي باسم جماعه
انصار الله الحوثيين اهلا بك سيد
محمد بدايه تعليقك على هذه العمليات التي
قامت بها امريكا وبريطانيا
ا بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم حياكم الله
واهلا وسهلا هذه العمليات الاجراميه التي
قام بها العدوان الامريكي البريطاني على
اليمن لا مبرره لها على الاطلاق ولا تستند
الى اي شرعيه اليمن لم يعتدي على احد
اليمن اعلن موقف مساند لفلسطين ومساند
لقطاع غزه الذي يتعرض لحصار اجرامي وقصف
همجي وقتل النساء والاطفال الموقف اليمني
في البحر الاحمر لم يستهدف اي دوله في
العالم باستثناء اسرائيل والتي تتجه الى
اسرائيل كرد طبيعي وفقا للاجرام
الاسرائيلي
المتجه الظالم بحق الشعب الفلسطيني ولذلك
نحن نعتبر ان ما حصل لي امس هو عدوان سافر
وغاشه لا مبرر له على الاطلاق لن لن يثني
اليمن عن موقفه تجاه فلسطين ولا يمكن ان
يكون هذا العمليات دون رد من قبل القوات
المسلحه اليمنيه وهو يثبت فاعليه الموقف
اليمني وصوابي الموقف اليمني الذي ينطلق
من مبدا ديني واخلاقي وانساني امام صمت
مريد تريد امريكا وبريطانيا ان تقتل
الفلسطينيين بصمت وحتى وقفت في مجلس الامن
لتع ض اي قرار يدعو الى وقف اطلاق النار
الذي يقف اغلب العالم الى جانبه فيما
تتحرك لتثمين عن موقفه البسيط والانساني
والاخلاقي الذي يجب ان يقفه الجميع ولهذا
نحن نعتقد ان هذا العدوان لن يجيد اليمن
الا صلابه وقوه وثباتا سواء في منع السفن
الاسرائيليه والمتجهه الى اسرائيل او في
الرد على العدوان الامريكي البريطاني طيب
لنفصل في كل نقطه جت على ذكرها سيد محمد
مد عبد السلام بدايه ما طبيعه الرد الذي
ستردون به على هذه الضربات ما السقف الذي
ستذهبون
اليه السقف هذا تحدده القوات المسلحه
واعتقد انها قد قامت بعمليه للرد الاولي
على الاستهداف الذي سقط فيه عدد من القوات
البحريه والان الرد بلا شك سيكون اوسع
والقوات المسلحه اليمنيه في هذه اللحظات
تدرس خيارات الرد ولا اتوقع ان يدوم الوقت
طويلا ربما نسمع ردا غريبا والرد تحدده
طبيعه المعركه وتحدياتها وكذلك التعامل مع
القصف الجوي والبحري الذي تعرض له اليمن
ولذلك الرد لا محال تقادم اكد السيد عبد
الملك في خطابين اننا لا يمكن ان تقصف
امريكا وبريطانيا اليمن ثم تقول انتهت
العمليه ثم نتوقف هذا مستحيل الرد قادم
لان هذا من حقنا المشروع الذي انتهك سياده
اليمن دون مبرر نحن لم نمثل اي تهديد لاي
دوله في الع العالم نحن لم نعتدي على احد
نحن نؤكد يوميا ان البحريه الملاحه
البحريه في اليمن امنه نحن نقول لكل
العالم ان يمروا بامان نحن نستهدف اسرائيل
ونستهدف السفن المتجهه اليها ردا للحصار
والقتل الاجرامي البشع الذي ضجت منه
الانسانيه في هذا الكرن ولم يوجد له مثيل
على الاطلاق ولهذا نحن نعتقد ان القوات
المسلحه سترد في القريب العاجل وطبيعه هذا
الرد سيسمعه الجميع ان شاء الله طيب
بالتزامن مع مع هذا الرد هل سيكون هناك
استمرار للعمليات التي تقومون بها ضد
السفن المتجهه لاسرائيل او السفن
الاسرائيليه نعم بالتاكيد
سيستمر العمل على استهداف السفن
الاسرائيليه والمتجهه الى اسرائيل من اي
بلد كانت هذا قرار اتخذناه لا رجعه عنه
الا بعد انتهاء العدوان الغاشم على فلسطين
وفك الحصار عن قطاع غزه ما عدا ذلك لا
يمكن ان نتردد بل بالعكس لقد جعل الامريكي
والبريطاني من عملياته بالامس ان يثبت ان
موقف اليمن ذات فاعليه وهو سيستمر فيه هم
قصفوا بالامس اليمن ب 68 غاره جويه وبحريه
من بارجات ومن غواصات واستهدفوا ب 68
توزعت على صنعاء وتوزعت على صعده والحديده
وعلى حجه وعلى محافظه تعز وهذا يثبت اولا
فاعليه الموقف اليمني ويثبت اهميه
الاستمرار في مسانده الشعب الفلسطيني
المظلوم ولذلك نؤكد من على شاشتكم ان
السفن الاسرائيليه او المتجهه الى اسرائيل
ما زالت ممنوعه كما نوضح لبقيه دول العالم
ان سفنهم امنه وعليهم ان يتجهوا الى
الامريكيين والبريطانيين بالتوقف عن عسكره
البحر الاحمر اذا تم عسكره البحر الاحمر
واصبح خطا ناريا معنى ذلك ستتاح الملاحه
الدوليه لكل الدول ولذلك نحن نحمل امريكا
وبريطانيا تبعات فعلتهم الشنيع والا
جراميه والغير مبرره بحق اليمن وما سيترتب
عليها من نتائج طيب ولكن سيد محمد انتم
تواجهون اساطيل في البحر الاحمر لدول عظمى
وكذلك ايضا تحالفا شكل بخصوص هذه العمليات
التي تقومون بها في هذه الضربه فقط تم
استهداف اكثر من سبعه مواقع داخل اليمن هل
لديكم القدره على مواجهه كل
ذلك دعيني اؤكد اولا انه لا يوجد تحالف
بحري في حقيقه الامر كل ما في امر هو
عدوان امريكي بريطاني نحن على تواصل مع كل
الدول حتى التي تذكر امريكا اسمائها في
بياناتها نحن على تواصل مباشر معهم واكدوا
ان موقفهم اما دعما سياسيا او من اجل
التنسيق لاجل سفنهم او تواجد ذرني تقصد
هنا الدول التي اعلنها جو بايدن استراليا
البحرين كندا هولندا تواصلت معهم نعم نعم
نعم نحن على تواصل مع اغلبهم وهم اكدوا
انهم ليسوا ضمن هذه العمليات وان تواجدهم
محدود باستشارات معينه اما في الاسطول
الخامس في البحرين او عبر اتصالات تنسيقيه
من اجل مرور سفنهم القصف الذي طال اليمن
هو امريكي بريطاني فقط ولذلك نحن نقول
العدوان هو امريكي وبريطاني لا يوجد له اي
شرعيه ولا يوجد له اي تحالف وهذا التحالف
هو مكشوف وحتى البيان الذي سطر من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه يقول بدعم
ونحن على تواصل مع هذه الدول واكدوا لنا
انهم لا علاقه لهم بما يجري ولا باي
عمليات من هذا القص اما بالنسبه للضرر
وبالنسبه للامكانات الحمد لله اليمن اليوم
لديه تجربه كبيره اثبت فاعليتها في عمليات
بحريه مقده وهو يستطيع ان ينتج السفن من
بين مئات من السفن المتواجده في البحر
والعسكريون يعرفون طبيعه وتعديد استهداف
سفن من بين سفن اخرى لاهداف متحركه وسفن
متشابهه ولذلك اثبت اليمن فاعليه هذا
الموقف ولولا ان الموقف كان فاعلا لم قرت
امريكا ان تعلن عن تحالف وان ان تملا
الدنيا ضجيجا الا من التاثير الموقف
اليمني اما بالنسبه للامكانات فنحن نستند
اولا ونتوكل على الله سبحانه وتعالى ون
ونعتمد ايضا على الشعب اليمني الذي يساند
هذه العمليات من اقصاه الى ادناه ونتوكل
ايضا على الله سبحانه وتعالى وعلى
مظلوميتها ومظلوم الشعب الفلسطيني لانها
مظلوميه محقه وهو سينتصر الدم على السيف
وسينتصر الحق على الباطل لاننا لسنا من
اعتدى عليهم هم من فتحوا معركه ظالمه وهم
من تجاهلوا القضيه الفلسطينيه لقرون من
الزمن وهم من اوصلوا المنطقه الى ما هي
عليه اليوم ولذلك نحن في الموقف المحق
ونحن مستعدون ان نقدم التضحيات تجاه ذلك
طيب سييد محمد على ذكر الضرر المواقع التي
استهدفت ما الاثار التي تسببت فيها هذه
الغارات
هناك الغارات التي استهدفت اليمن هي ثمان
غارات في صنعاء استهدفت قاعده الديلمي
واستهدفت بعض الهناجر حصل فيها حروق معينه
كذلك الذي في صعده استهدفت جبال ومعسكرات
سبد وحتى
انصفت في تسع سنوات كذلك الذي في الحديده
16 غاره استهدفت ايضا المطار واستهدفت بعض
المديريات وكذلك في حجه استهدفت ايضا بعض
المناطق وبعض القرى فيها وفي تعز كذلك بعض
في معسكر اللواء 22 تسع غارات مجملها في
تعز هناك عدد من الشهداء وهناك جرحى لكن
لا يوجد هناك اضرار حقيقيه لا على المستوى
المادي او على مستوى الاستراتيجي ما زالت
القدرات العسكريه تقوم بعمليات حتى الان
واليمن والقوات المسلحه اليمنيه لديها
تجربه كبيره في التعامل مع العمليات
الجويه والصاروخيه وطيران الاستطلاع وباذن
الله تعالى وتوفيقه لن يحصل اي اضرار
طالما هناك يقظه وهناك تحرك شعبي كبير لا
يستند فيه الامريكي والبريطاني الى اي
حليف يمكن ان يقدم له اي معلومات باستثناء
ما يحصل عليها من طيران الاستطلاع وفي
الغالب اليمن واسع لا يستطيع ان يتحقق من
كثير من الاعمال فنستطيع ان نقول ان هذه
العمليات ليست مؤثره وليست ذات قيمه
فاعليه صحيح سقط لنا شهداء وجرحى في طريق
الجهاد المقدس في الفتح الموعود والجهاد
المقدس في قضيه فلسطين وهذه ضريبه نحن
مستعدون لدفعها للدفاع عن كرامه عن
كرامتنا وعن شعب فلسطين المظلوم طيب هل
اعطيتنا سيد محمد ارقام من قتلوا وايضا
رحوا ما زالت الاعداد تتوارد لكن هم ليسوا
بالعدد الكبير هم قد يكونوا اقل حتى من
العشرات ما بين
الجرحى والشهداء الاعداد ل لم نستكملها
بعد ما زالت التحريات والتحقيقات جاريه
وسنصدر بيانات ان شاء الله تفصيليه اذا
تطلب الامر ذلك طيب سيد محمد كنتم حذرت من
خطوره عسكره البحر الاحمر من جانبكم كيف
ستضمن عدم عسكره البحر الاحمر بالفعل
الذي يضمن عدم عسكره البحر الاحمر هو
الامريكي والبريطاني هو الذي جاء ب بارجه
الى شواطئنا هو الذي جاء ببار جاته
وحاملات الطائرات الى الى شواطئ اليمن وهو
الذي اطلق النار من البحر باتجاه اليمن
نحن
اطلقنا استهداف على سفن اسرائيليه لم يسقط
فيها جريحا واحدا ولم حتى تحصل خسائر
ماديه كبيره سفينه جلاكسي ليدر التي تم
سحبها الى موانئ الحديده لم صب فيها واحد
شخص واحد عمليات نظيفه ودقيقه مثلت ضغطا
حقيقيا على الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي ومثلت
ضغطا حقيقيا على اسرائيل لردعها والتوقف
عن عدوانها في غزه الذي عسكر البحر الاحمر
هو من اسال الدماء في البحر الاحمر وهو من
سيتحمل النتائج نحن موقفنا سيكون رده فعل
ولهذا نحن نقول بصوت واحد ان على جميع
الدول وخاصه الدول العربيه والمشاط للبحر
الاحمر ان يكون لها صوت واضح في في في عدم
استمراريه وجود البارجات
وتكثيف القطع العسكريه في البحر الاحمر
لانها لم تاتي خدمه لشعوب المنطقه لم تاتي
من اجل اليمن لم تاتي من اجل السعوديه لم
تاتي من اجل امن مصر لم تاتي من اجل امن
السودان او جيبوتي لم تاتي من امن من اجل
امن مناطقنا جاءت من اجل امن واستقرار
وخدمه اسرائيل اسرائيل من التي تحتل اراضي
الامه تحتل اراضي فلسطين وتنتهك لقرون من
الزمن تنتهك اسرائيل
الشعب الفلسطيني استيطان وقتلا في الضفه
وفي غزه وهي قصه معروفه لا يحتاج الى شرح
لذلك من يتحمل المسؤوليه هو من فرض هذه
البوارج وهذه القطع العسكريه ان تتواجد في
البحر الاحمر ولذلك عسكرته معنا ان يكون
ساحه للحرب واذا ما تحول الى ساحه حربيه
فستتحول امريكا النتائج المترتبه على ذلك
شكرا جزيلا لك محمد عبد السلام الناطق
الرسمي باسم جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين l